bonjour je me présente marina charmant
donc je viens de la petite île je suis
natif de la ravine des cabris j'ai 28
ans je me suis présenté au challenge et
créateurs dans la catégorie emploi afin
de justement créer mon propre emploi et
créer une dynamique par la suite donc ma
société s'appelle le créole on est une
salle de réception sur le sud donc la
salle peut recevoir 150 couverts à 6 et
200 personnes debout donc la salle et
est située à bois d'olives saint pierre
la salle en termes de services propose à
un service clé en main donc qui comprend
logistique
tables chaises sono animateurs déco
service en table service bar le traiteur
se retrouvent pas oublier le traiteur
donc c'est vraiment un
un service complet qu'on propose la
semaine nous travaillons aussi avec du
public quelques les associations et le
week-end on bat ce que justement sur
l'événementiel qui moi même la gérante
organise de a à z
l'événement pour que le client soit
satisfait à 200% j'ai un bts assistant
de gestion pme pmi donc un niveau
licence en management donc ça je me suis
dit que c'est la suite logique vu la
conjoncture actuelle pour trouver un
travail c'est pas évident donc je me
suis dit ça passe ou ça casse donc je
givet et dans le futur j'aimerais
justement et on est en train de faire
tout pour développer le secteur traiteur
parce qu on le fait dans la salle
c'était en fait mais on travaille aussi
à l'extérieur on veut vraiment touché
tout il